foreign
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar challenges in implementing
capillary electrophoresis for
immunotyping
I am Kaylee Bach of labyrinths and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by Sabia to learn more visit sabia.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
and with that I'd like to know welcome
our speaker Dr Jack majorie medical
director Regional core laboratory and
point of care testing assistant
professor pathology and laboratory
medicine Loyola University Medical
Center Dr majorie you may now begin your
presentation
thank you for that kind introduction and
thank you for joining us today to allow
me to share with you some of the stories
and challenges that we've had in
implementing capillary electrophoresis
and for immunotyping and how we've
overcome some of these challenges
here's our learning objectives for today
I'd like you to be able to at the end of
this presentation be able to discuss the
need for this type of testing recall
some of the analytical principles that
are used in the technologies that I'll
be describing today and then list some
of the advantages and disadvantages of
each of the Technologies
and finally discuss the challenges faced
when implementing new laboratory
Technologies
and finally to properly apply the phrase
It's subtle but it's there
for disclosure
I'm receiving no honorarium nor other
form of compensation from Savia or lab
roots today and providing this webinar
and the opinions expressed today are
solely mine and are really not meant to
be considered an endorsement for any of
the products that I'm describing today
so you may ask yourself why am I
participating this webinar and it's
strictly for educational purposes I'd
like to share with you some of the
challenges that we've experienced and
how we've worked with Sabia to overcome
these challenges in adopting a new
technology
in today's presentation we'll talk about
the analytical methods used for this
type of testing
I'll apply a comparison of principles so
you can see the advantages and
disadvantages you'll be able to see a
number of cases Illustrated side by side
so you can see the advantages and
disadvantages of each of the
Technologies
so I need to start with an essential
question
what diagnoses are supported by the
findings of immunofixation and
immunotyping so build in your mind the
reason we do this testing in your first
play in the first place and I'm sure
you'll bring to mind
plasma cell dysgrasias it's broad
category for why we do this testing
monoclonal gammopathies it's what we're
searching for by employing these methods
multiple myeloma unfortunately the
diagnosis that is
given to patients who are discovered to
have
plasma cell production of monoclonal
proteins
and light chain disease we're learning a
lot more about light change light chain
disease and how these Technologies are
being used in this diagnostic process as
well
like to start with looking at a
celebrity with multiple myeloma and I'm
always asked why do I use celebrities
whenever I'm doing a presentation well
first of all
celebrities help to humanize the disease
process we look at numbers we look at
figures we look at patterns we look at
cells
but we don't always remember that we're
we're dealing with patients and we're
dealing with patient lives so putting a
face to a disease is helpful celebrities
also help to bring additional awareness
education sometimes and important
funding to understanding more about a
disease process and how to implement
cures
okay so here's a celebrity and I'm going
to go through some quotes So if you're
playing at home see how many Clues it
takes for you to get this celebrity
you may ask yourself do I feel lucky
maybe about this immunolabulin
identification
they say marriages are made in heaven
but so is thunder and lightning that's
from The Good the Bad and the Ugly
right turn Clyde from any which way you
can
and finally get off my lawn
from Gran Torino and by now most of you
know we're talking about
Clint Eastwood so Papa's nails
survived a long time with multiple
myeloma
but again associating patients
associating with celebrities sometimes
help to get them through the process
make them realize that others maybe
Heroes of theirs are going through the
same types of struggles
we'll have some more celebrities as we
go through this presentation
so a review of the analytical methods
from Sabia Diagnostics we perform
protein electrophoresis and immunotyping
by immunofixation and immunosubtraction
shown
at the upper right here is the hydrosis
hydrogel it uses agarose gel
electrophoresis or serum protein
electrophoresis and immunofixation
in the lower right you see the
capillaris three Terra
it employs capillary electrophoresis
Technologies to allow for serum protein
electrophoresis and immunosubtraction
slightly different principle than
immunofixation
here's an example of a hydrogel serum
protein electrophoresis this is
available in 30
uh well or 54 sample well formats this
could be used for serum urine and
cerebral spinal fluid it's an agarose
gel platform it's run in an agarose
buffer with a pH of approximately 8.5
requires a small sample volume about 10
microliters it's run at a relatively low
voltage to achieve the separation that
you see most anodally you'll see albumin
followed by the globulins Alpha 1 Alpha
2 beta 1 beta 2 these are the restricted
bands that you see for the physiological
globulins and finally the gamma region
nice polyclonal somewhat symmetrical
more of a Feather type of appearance and
you'll see a few restricted bands
included here in this example
here's where the sample is applied where
it were indicated
and there's migration that occurs toward
the anode or toward the cathode
depending on the properties of the
protein after the separation the gel is
dried
it's fixed and stained with Amino black
dye which gives this deep bluish
appearance of the proteins
and the interpretation of the results
depends on the qualitative visual
inspection of the gel just as I
previously pointed out we see restricted
bands here in Lane 2 and Lane 10 these
are abnormal findings that need to be
investigated
and the proteins
in these various zones are quantitated
by densitometry
moving on to immunofixation
electrophoresis using the hydrogel here
this the sample the same sample is
applied to all six lanes and shown here
is a three by three gel platforms after
electrophoresis the gel is dried
in the interpretation of the results
again is primarily based on the
qualitative visual inspection of the gel
so let's look at some examples that I've
highlighted here remember the same
sample is applied to all six Lanes so
looking at this lower left example
we have
in the first plane serum protein
electrophoresis and then we have
immunostaining specific for the heavy
chains
IGG IGA and IGM and the light chains
either Kappa or Lambda so we see a
restriction in the serum protein
electrophoresis Lane and as we move
horizontal from that restriction we see
that there's also a restricted band in
the presence of IGG and also in Lambda
so we identify this restricted band as
an IGG Lambda these can get more
complicated having several monoclonal
proteins at times so here we have an IGA
Lambda and also an IGG Cat book so this
is just meant to illustrate how we use
immunofixational electrophoresis and the
specific immunostaining to identify the
construct of a monoclonal protein
so something else to keep in mind the
acid Violet stain is 20 times more
sensitive than Amino black so we have a
tendency to see
more proteins or better resolution of
the proteins using the hydrogel
immunofixation with the acid Violet
staining
moving on to our newer technology what
we're describing today is the capillaris
capillary electrophoresis so the
capillar is three principle is shown
here where you have
negatively charged capillary walls
we have the extra Electro osmotic Force
this is the force that's stronger than
the force of the electrical field
and this is the direction of the protein
migration then it will follow the
electro osmotic Force
or typically used to seeing
albumin our most prominent Peak at the
anodial
end of the migration using the
principles of capillary electrophoresis
the gamma proteins gamma globulins are
going to elute first
toward the cathodal end now this image
will be turned around for us to help
with a consistent interpretation but you
should know that this is the direction
of the protein migration this is the the
force that's at play that allows for the
physical separation
the Sabia automated system has 12 silica
capillaries
very small bore
the sample size is very small as well
just one Nano one nanoliter
it uses an alkaline buffer a little bit
more alkaline than what we see with the
gel based Technologies migration time is
shortened quite a bit five minutes and
this is achieved because of higher
voltage
and this is a direct detection we don't
rely on staining of the protein
components this is a direct detection of
the protein components at 200 nanometers
spread at the cathode end so these
proteins will emerge catholically
and we could run in an automated fashion
up to 120 samples so eight samples and
15 distinct racks
this is what the phoresis software so
Sabia has a software that is able to
help with the visualization so we don't
have to run a gel through a densitometer
we're able to see these patterns
directly
through the foresis software and what to
point out first of all we have a
pre-albumin band we don't see our pre
albumin Peak
and totally to the albumin so we don't
typically see a pre-albumin peak
on the gel electrophoresis so you start
to see an increased degree of
sensitivity already but we have our our
familiar Alpha One Alpha two beta 1 beta
2 and then the gamma region yes we've
got an obvious monoclonal Protein that's
been identified in the anodial gamma
region so this is serum protein
electrophoresis and notice that there is
for those who like the familiarity of
the gel
a computer simulated gel pattern that's
included in the visualization so here's
our monoclonal Peak and here is the the
band that would be analogous to this
peak in the anodol gamma region
moving on to the
immunotyping okay so this is different
from aminal fixation because we're not
fixing and we're not staining
immunotyping
has six
automatically or six simultaneously run
injections through the capillaries
the first is the electrophoresis okay so
this is the same pattern that you saw
with the electrophoresis
run
and you see it here it's a yellow
background so this are yellow tracing so
this is going to serve as our background
for each of the other capillaries what
happens before the injection is samples
have
antibodies against the heavy chains and
the light chains added prior to their
injection what those antibodies are set
against are the heavy chain so IGG
IGA and IGM and the light chains Kappa
and Lambda so we see the same yellow
background pattern in each of these six
capillary tracings
and what you see in blue
sometimes appearing as green because of
a perfect overlay the blue is the the
image for which the immunosubtraction
takes place so we see
are in the IGG
frame here
the IGG has been fully immuno subtracted
IGA has been retained IGM has been
retained and for the Kappa and Lambda
light chains you see the Kappa fully
subtracted but the Lambda is retained so
this is a clear example just to
illustrate an IGG Kappa monoclonal
protein
what are the advantage advantages and
disadvantages of these Technologies well
on the plus side for immunofixation
it is more widely used it's been used
for many decades it's become probably
the most common way of
performing this test
so there is increased familiarity of
staff and the reviewers
also on a positive note we're looking
for the presence of a band not the
absence of a peak so we're looking for
something that's there and not for
something that's disappearing so that
could be considered a Plus on the
negative side immunofixation relies on
stain intensity to identify a restricted
band
also a limitation of the
immunofixational electrophoresis is we
do not have the ability to differentiate
between the beta 1 and beta 2 globulins
so it's not it's not a high resolution
of the beta region beta globulin region
another disadvantage is this the
physical storage requirement to
physically store the gels after the
testing is performed and then to
retrieve them on demand or upon request
we also cannot differentiate between
multiple light chains that may
co-migrate with a heavy chain so I'll
illustrate one of the problems
associated with this type of finding
probably the main disadvantage is the
manual processing the Hands-On time
required for immunofixation
electrophoresis sensitivity is also
identified as a disadvantage it's a
dilution dependent process
so if we have to dilute our sample
because of high protein content we may
miss some of the components that are
present as monoclonal proteins and low
concentration and this is highly
technique dependent as reviewers we have
a tendency to recognize who's performed
the run for today when it comes to gels
because the techniques related to
application blotting handling really are
reflective of the appearance of the gel
patterns so highly manual and highly
technique dependent
moving to capillary
immunosubtraction electrophoresis this
has been shown to be much more
reproducible from run to run we see
almost the same pattern even from day to
day so much more highly reproducible
this measures protein concentration and
not staying intensity so this is a
direct measurement of the proteins of
Interest we have digital storage of
electropherograms so no more clunky gel
storage in file cabinets or card
catalogs
we do have the ability to see the
immunofixation the same as we see our
high resolution protein electrophoresis
we're able to differentiate the beta 1
and beta 2 globulins which becomes
important for identifying those Killer
Bees the IGA and sometimes IGM proteins
that have a tendency to migrate in the
beta
beta 2 region so there's better
differentiation of light chains when
they are co-migrating so I'll illustrate
this
is much more fully automated so we've
got a way to
reduce the Hands-On time
and also reduce the skill level
associated with the specialty of
Performing electrophoresis so we're be
we're becoming much more highly
automated and much less Hands-On time
required which is a major advantage
these days with our current Staffing
shortages it's also much less technique
dependent
which goes along with the
reproducibility
some of the disadvantages it may be more
subjective for Peak subtraction so we're
looking for the subtraction of the peak
which in low concentrations may become
difficult
and at least early on in the adoption
process there's a decreased consensus
among reviewers which is able to be
overcome with familiarity additional
training and just going through uh
challenging cases working with technical
support from Sabia they're able to help
us resolve some of the discordant or
lack of consensus observations that are
made during the interpretation
a very important article and I have to
congratulate Dr Thorin and her
colleagues at Memorial Sloan Kettering
for having this article in the Journal
of Applied laboratory medicine in 2021
where equivalence was declared between
immunofixation and immunotyping
it really is a
a moment of Declaration that we as
scientists turn to experts in the field
like this to say maybe it's time to move
to or toward this technology
okay but as I look through this article
maybe not so fast so just to explain
some of the
agreement
challenges that were experienced by this
expert team so I have a question mark
here equivalence declared well you see
we've got excellent positive agreement
98 I'm saying we as if I was part of
this group and I wasn't but what was
published here was 98 positive agreement
with a monoclonal protein Spike
identification so this shows that the
two technologies are able to with great
equivalence detect the presence of a
monoclonal protein Spike
look at some of the specific monoclonal
bands in the positive agreement and you
see some problems when it comes to the
free Kappa and free Lambda monoclonal
Peaks that are light chains okay so only
20 agreement 29 agreement for free
Capital free Lambda respectively but we
have to keep in mind these were very low
concentrations so the challenge was put
to the team and they showed that in very
low concentrations
the immunotyping is able to with better
sensitivity identify these low
concentrations so where there is
discordance it's in favor of the
immunotyping being able to pick up
previously missed or possibly borderline
or questionable findings that were
encountered during immunofixation
but again I really have to complement
this group in the work that they've done
in publishing these findings and
instilling confidence in those of us who
were tentative or maybe not so ready to
take the sleep to adopt the new
technologies okay time for another
celebrity with a multiple myeloma here's
our Clues
he was detective Sonny Grosso in The
French Connection back in 1971
famous movie
he played Bob Fosse and all that jazz in
1979 so went from detective to
choreographer
he started in the 2001 A Space Odyssey
sequel 2010 the year we made contact
and maybe what he's most famous for
his most quoted line is you're going to
need a bigger boat from Jaws in 1975
so I'm sure you called to mind
Roy Scheider unfortunately we lost Roy
Scheider to multiple myeloma and it was
later disclosed at that line you're
going to need a bigger boat was
improvised but still kept in the movie
by Steven Spielberg
okay so let's go through some
challenging cases but first one more
fairly straightforward case
here's our serum protein electrophoresis
we've got an obvious monoclonal protein
in the mid gamma region okay so again
albumin alpha 1 Alpha 2 beta 1 beta 2
gamma region with an obvious monoclonal
Spike next we have to identify what is
the construct of this monoclonal protein
what are they heavy in in heavy and
light chains heavy chains and light
chains so you see again reproduce in
frame one serum protein electrophoresis
is reproduced showing our monoclonal
protein
if you look at the gamma region you see
that the
yellow Spike remains but what's been
immunosubtracted looking at the blue
tracing is IGG so again we have an IGG
where does it go so when the
immunosubtraction occurs
it's taken out of our area of
interpretation and brought in an area
where we're not really trying to
identify so albumin alpha 1 region this
is where the weighted down monoclonal
protein so the antibody against IGG
heavy chain weighs down that protein
literally and causes it to migrate
slower so this is toward the anodal end
and this is taken out of our area of
interpretation our area of Interest so
this is what this blue background
is in the albumin region if you look at
the IGA and IGM heavy chains there is no
immunosubtraction so there's no
IGA component of this monoclonal protein
if you look at the Lambda I'm sorry the
Kappa light chains you see what's left
behind in this gamma region is a nice
polyclonal
distribution the peak the yellow Peak
is shown as a background but what's been
subtracted is the IGA I'm sorry the
Kappa light chain and again as it's
removed is taken out of this area of
interpretation and moved toward the
albumin and Alpha One region
looking at the Lambda region you see
that there is some subtraction and this
is the polyclonal Lambda light chain
subtraction which is subtracted from
this area under this peak but it still
retains the peak shape so this is an
important takeaway is even though
there's some subtraction the peak shape
is retained in the Lambda
immunosubtraction meaning that Lambda is
not a component of this monoclonal
protein again we've got an IGG Kappa
monoclonal protein
so here's our monoclonal Peak here it is
subtracted in the IGG and here it is
again subtracted in the Kappa region
okay more challenging cases
really why we're here today so this is a
gel
immunofixation and this is difficult to
interpret we see a restricted band
that's clear that's obvious and we know
it has an IGM component as a heavy chain
but are we looking at an IGM Kappa or an
IGM Lambda and this is kind of a broad
type of of peak as well kind of
confusing so we do need a better look at
this so let's see how this case looks
using immunosubtraction
so first our serum protein
electrophoresis
again albumin alpha 1 Alpha 2 beta 1
beta 2 and Gamma you see that this
monoclonal protein is partially
migrating or overcoming the beta 2
glavulin
but we need to identify this monoclonal
peak what's happening here under this
curve
okay so what we first need to
identify
as we're trained by Sabia is let's look
at the light chains first the tendency
is and even in my previous example
jumping right to the heavy chains let's
see what we're talking about in the
heavy chains first but we're trained to
look at the light chains okay so as we
look at this region
you see that there is immunosubtraction
of the Kappa light chain there's
immunosubtraction of the Lambda light
chain but it's occurring on opposite
ends of this somewhat broader monoclonal
protein
okay so that's the first place to look
let's look back at our heavy chains
there's really no
immunosubtraction for the IGG heavy
chain no Amino subtraction for the IGA
heavy chain but we do see full
subtraction of the IGM heavy chain
What's Left Behind
is a nice polyclonal gamma region and we
start to see our beta 2 globulins as
well so this is a full subtraction but
what's happening in these light chains
why are they both being retained
okay so again looking at the IGM
we see that there are
what's What's Left Behind are the beta2
globulins and a polyclonal gamma region
the in the Kappa
immunosubtraction what we see indicated
in with the blue arrow is subtraction on
the cathodal side of this peak
so if
Kappa is retained but there's something
being subtracted on the cathodal side
that must mean that there is a Lambda
light chain present
so red is what's retained blue is what's
being subtracted now if we look in the
Lambda light chain box we see that in
the cathodal region
we've got retention of the peak but
we've got subtraction in the anodal side
so that must mean that there is a Kappa
light chain present as well
okay so this tells us that this is not
one monoclonal protein but two both IGM
but and IGM Kappa
on the cathodal side in an IGM Lambda on
the anodal site
okay so just to better illustrate this
an anodial IGM Lambda
and a cathodal IGM Kappa
so we look at the removal of the heavy
chain IGM it's not IGG or IGA
and what is subtracted
on the cathodal side what is subtracted
here is the Lambda component and on the
anodial side what is subtracted is the
Kappa component so we have two light
chains in this Channel and two
monoclonal proteins of different light
chain construct in this challenging
example
looking again at the gel
you can decide for yourself what gives
you better differentiation do we see
clearly C2
IGM components IGM
heavy chains
we do see a a light chain for Kappa and
a light chain for Lambda but this is a
judgment call whether we're calling this
two igms or an IGM Kappa with a Lambda
light chain or an IGM Lambda with a
capital light chain or two o-migrating
IGM monoclonal proteins one Kappa and
one Lambda so it's much better
Illustrated using the immunosubtraction
okay let's take a breath look at one
more celebrity here's the clues
he had the brain of Abby normal in Young
Frankenstein one of my favorite movies
there's a piece of trivia John Lennon
was his best man at his wedding in 1977.
he co-starred with Robert De Niro in
scorsese's Taxi Driver in 1976 and maybe
his most famous for the character he
created Frank Barone and Everybody Loves
Raymond
Okay so
Peter Boyle is our celebrity
and unfortunately we lost Peter Boyle to
multiple myeloma back in 2006.
moving on to another challenging case
so this is difficult to interpret
there's an IGA Lambda
but is there an IGG
Kappa
or Lambda this is that very clear so
let's look at the advantages of the
immunosubtraction and identifying what's
at play here
okay so here's our question marks what
are we seeing in these regions
okay now this clear-cut as our previous
example but we see we've got
another broad type of monoclonal
structure in the gamma region
again the tendency is to want to look
right at the heavy chains but let's
start with the light chains
Kappa what we see here on the
ethyl side is a reduction so that must
mean that there is a Lambda component
but there's something retained here on
the anodal side of this broad Peak so we
start to think to ourselves this is not
just one these are two proteins that are
partially co-migrating
let's look at our Lambda
What's Happening Here is we see the
retention of the shape on the cathodal
side but on the anodal side we see a
subtraction
so this must mean that there is a Kappa
component on the annual side
so looking at the IGG heavy chain you
see there's reduction on the cathodal
side and what's being retained here in
the shape of a peak on the anodal side
tells us that there's another heavy
chain that's involved in this area under
this broader Peak
okay if you look at where the
subtraction is taking place so
subtraction on the cathodal side
an IGG and that's coinciding with the
subtraction of the Kappa and the
retention of the Lambda
so IGG remains
on the
anodal side along with the the Lambda
looking at IGA here we see retention of
most of the peak shape but there is
reduction on the anodal side
so this is a co-migrating peak of IgA
with an IGG
what we have here IGA is reduced along
with Lambda so we have an IGA Lambda
shown as the red arrow
and an IGG
Kappa
shown here
with the red arrow
to look at IGM just to make sure there's
no involvement here
you see no Amino subtraction no
reduction
so a summary
again more challenging case but we do
see these from time to time you see the
difficulty in the gel
you see the difficulty in having to look
systematically at the areas of
immunosubtraction
so we've got removal of IGG on the
cathodal side along with removal of
Kappa
on the anodal side we have removal of
IgA along with Lambda so we've got our
IGG Kappa green arrows and an IGA Lambda
Lambda the orange arrows
and again looking back at the gel
maybe the IGA Lambda
is more easy to interpret more apparent
by looking at this gel but we have lots
of question marks what's happening in
this
IGG in Kappa region
okay
great for another celebrity
he's an American statesman or was an
American statesman Diplomat and Four
Star General
they don't really use that term
Statesman much these days
he rose to Fame in Operation Desert
Storm
2003 he raised awareness
about Anthrax and biological warfare
agents
and he was our 65th U.S Secretary of
State
and of course we're talking about
General Colin Powell
who lost General Powell to multiple
myeloma and complications of covid in
2021.
one more challenging case
is this a directumia mob ban so
deratumia map also known as darzalex is
an immunotherapy that is given to
patients with multiple myeloma to
decrease the production it helps to
facilitate the decreased production of
monoclonal proteins the effect the
monophonal proteins the negative effect
the monoclonal proteins have so this is
a patient who was populated on our
darzalex list by our Pharmacy so we knew
that this patient was on darzalex and
this is where we typically see our
darzalex band in the Catholic gamma
region and protein electrophoresis
but is this the dinosaur and darzalex or
deratumimab is IGG Kappa like the
monoclonal protein immunotherapies
they're all IGG Kappa monoclonal
proteins what we're seeing here and this
is a
a printed version not using the farisa
software so these are the printed
reports that we receive when we're
reviewing
these results shows that there's
retention of the Kappa region under this
suspected Peak where we thought we were
dealing with darzalex and there's full
immunosubtraction in the Lambda region
so of course the reviewer
happened to be me puts a question mark
this is a patient we're expecting
darzalex but it's not removal of IGG and
Kappa which would have told us an IGG
Capital where we suspected it but we
identify that this is an IGG Lambda
how is that possible so
we asked for a gel just to confirm this
immunosubtraction so going the opposite
direction this time so on the gel what
we see is in the anodial gamma region we
see an IGG Kappa
interesting finding and in the Catholic
gamma region we see an IGG Lambda
so we would normally expect to see a
very faint restricted band in the
cathodal gamma region if we were dealing
with darzalex
this is not a darzoflex band despite the
fact that this patient was populated on
the list
this is not a dare to me map of band
and again you may say I really don't see
that Lambda is it there but no I'm
telling you it's subtle but it's there
the resolution is not great in this
reproduce image but there is an IGG
Lambda light very faint restricted band
in the cathode gamma region
this has become my tagline when I'm
working with immunofixation in teaching
the resonance
so
did we miss the anodial gamma the Enola
gamma IGG Kappa band do we see anything
in this endodal gamma region well
suppose it's easy to overlook
but again it's a very small
Peak that is appearing in the anodal
gamma region
maybe so subtle that it would miss most
reviewers eyes
but it is there so we are seeing
removal of IGG under this small slightly
raised area and slight removal of Kappa
again you be the judge
what is easier to interpret these types
of findings that are slow so low in
concentration but we need to identify
their presence okay so maybe a little
bit more apparent in this example in the
gel than on the immuno subtraction
but whenever there is a question about
interpretation of results we can turn to
immunofixation for confirmatory testing
or to help resolve questionable results
or results that are not consistent with
the patient's history
on the topic of geritumiumab this paper
that was published by Dr Karen in
Associates in Ann Arbor
help to confirm what we're seeing here
for
immunosubtraction immunotyping for the
darzalex band
on serum protein electrophoresis and gel
electrophoresis we're more accustomed to
seeing the darzalex band in the cathol
gamma region
with immunotyping in capillary
electrophoresis the Stars will expand
has a tendency to be a little bit more
mid- gamma to near cathodal gamma so
this was a nice study that showed based
on the x-axis where darzalex is known to
migrate
so again very helpful when colleagues
publish information that you're seeing
but really have not had enough
experience to confirm what you're
visualizing
and whenever you're dealing with
serotoniumab remember there is a product
and this is not a commercial this is
just something that is used to help
remove these monoclonal proteins these
immunotherapies from your area of view
so you can better see the monoclonal
proteins of Interest so there's not an
overlay or any kind of
misinterpretation so you could remove
from your area of view there to Meb by
applying the Hydra shift
um antibodies so these are this is a
product available that causes a shift to
take that IGG Kappa out of your area of
interest and move it
more anodally out of your view so you
can actually see what's left behind or
what is not being masked by the darzalex
what about this case last case
challenging case as well maybe looks
fairly normal the little beta gamma
bridging this beta 2 Peak maybe a little
bit broader than usual but even the gel
the simulated gel doesn't really show
much to be concerned about maybe a
little bit thicker maybe a little bit
more intensity so this is an area of
Suspicion this beta 2 region
and that's what we'll have a closer look
at when we do our immunosubtraction
okay so here is that immunosubtraction
again reproduced from the printed
um
version
and what we see subtracted in the IGA
region is in this anodial region of the
beta 2 area we see subtraction which
coincides with subtraction of the Lambda
light chain
what's retained here is the Kappa light
chain normally
Lambda is about one-third and Kappa is
about two-thirds so when you see a
larger reduction for Lambda then Kappa
this may be an indication that there is
a monoclonal protein at play here
also look at what's retained so we see
retention for the IGG heavy chains for
retention of the IGM heavy chains so
this is our area of concern IGA Lambda
we did choose to confirm this by gel
and here you see this immunofixation gel
which color clearly shows that we are
dealing with an IGG Lambda
and the migration is in the beta region
again this is there's no high resolution
electrophoresis so this appears to be a
little bit more toward the inter beta
gamma region
okay so again you see the advantage of
the immuno subtraction
being able to identify the beta 1 and
beta 2 physiological proteins globulins
and where subtraction occurs what is
Left Behind is the normal
beta tube globulins
okay
other implementation challenges so this
does require extensive validation for
both serum and urine electrophoresis we
did complete both validations
what I've shown you today are examples
for serum urine is still in the process
of rolling out live because it takes a
lot of
laboratory information system
programming changes as well but we saw
very strong agreement so we did have to
investigate discordance but less than 10
percent of cases showed lack of
agreement so 90 agreement for serum so
we were very pleased with that gave us a
lot of reassurance that we were using
the technology that was not going to
cause us a lot of difficulty the main
source of discordance was previously
unidentified monoclonal protein low
concentrations uh missed interpretation
a very faint bands uh subjective
interpretation where we
did not
um identify the bands previously but saw
them and then pre and then subsequently
confirm them using the immuno
subtraction
using capillary electrophoresis and
immunotyping we did have to adjust our
reference interval for albumin Alpha One
in gamma this is a more sensitive method
so it's less subjective less reliant on
staining intensity and more able to
identify proteins it may not stain as
intensely
we did have to change our interpretation
comments so wherever we had mentioned
restricted bands now we had to change
that to abnormal Peaks we have more than
coded comments these are shorthand
comments a language that was developed
by Dr Earl Holmes Dr Holmes has a
tendency to to come up with systems that
allow for increased efficiency and this
is another example so for example the
phrase Hess I Ferg means or translates
to high resolution electrophoresis with
this what of the serum with protein
staining shows the presence of a tiny
restriction in the gamma region since
we're dealing with immunosubtraction
we're not looking at
uh bands but we're looking for the
appearance or The Disappearance of Peaks
so we have to change that to chess
c-i-t-p-g which now translates to high
resolution capillary electrophoresis of
the serum shows a presence of a tiny
peak in the gamma region so this had to
be
wet tested or dry tested of using our
laboratory information system teams
assistance
and the installation and testing of the
farisa software also had to be tested as
part of our implementation process
continuing more challenges yes we did
have to have a new standard operating
procedure
we participated in extensive training
for our staff our performing staff and
reviewers we did have to notify our
Hematology Oncology ordering positions
of the anticipated changes
and we chose to retain our hydrosis
immunofixation
and serum protein electrophoresis as
backup now we're using only the
immunofixation right now on the hydra's
hydro system as backup and only to
investigate results that are
inconsistent with the patient's history
or if we feel we could use confirmation
of a pattern that may not be
particularly clear
so what are we finding for our areas of
discordance we're finding that we're
seeing a lot more IGM lambdas and the
anodal gamma region again these are
subtle but they are present and these
are confirmed findings as well we're
also seeing more monoclonal Peaks for
free light chains that were previously
not detected or maybe questioned and
required subsequent testing to confirm
findings
but the goal here for the need for
confirmatory testing is 10 so we would
like to say that 90 of our immunofix our
immunosubtraction
immunotyping using capillary
electrophoresis will not require
confirmatory testing or subsequent
testing by gel and we're currently at 15
to 20 percent after one year after go
live so we're getting there and with
additional training and help technical
support from Savia to help understand
some of the questionable findings or
maybe to add some clarity we're reducing
the note the need for the gel testing
but retain it nonetheless for this
purpose
other celebrities with multiple myeloma
other notables Sam Walton and Landers
advice columnists former vice
presidential candidate Geraldine Ferraro
Tom Brokaw Hayden York from I Dream of
Jeannie Caroline McWilliams from uh
Benson so these these celebrities some
of them are very forward very open with
their struggle and that does help to
raise awareness and funding
and unfortunately we have lost others
just to show that this this condition is
is deadly and is in need of continued
improvements for Technologies for
earlier detection and better treatment
uh my phrase is subtle but it's there in
my faculty roast last year I was
reminded that I use this term quite a
bit when I'm doing teaching and training
with our pathology residents it is a
phrase that's used to convince
questioning or inquisitive residence
whether we're actually seeing a finding
that I see but they're maybe not able to
see
but it also
interestingly enough describes our
behind the scenes contributions to this
testing as reviewers in the process
before we hand over our initial
interpretations to our hematology
pathologist for their final
interpretation and sign off
and I can tell you after reviewing
thousands of serum protein
electrophoresis
densitometry tracings and immunofixation
patterns you start to see Peaks where
normal people don't see Peaks so here
Kleenex box there's an abnormal Peak
that jumps out at me it can't even look
at Clouds anymore without seeing Peaks
appearing where I should see Tufts and
relaxing patterns
went to the Smoky Mountains last year
with my wife and I looked at this
mountain range and said do you see an
abnormal peak in the cathodal gamma
region and I got a strange look
but interestingly enough that Peak is
identified as Stone Mountain in
Tennessee
my references are shown here including
the references that I shared from Dr
thorin's group Dr Karen's group with
those important Publications
oil University Medical Center I had the
honor and privilege of working with many
amazing colleagues here this is our
brand new Regional core laboratory
highly automated back in this area this
corner of laboratory is where we have
our electrophoresis set up a little bit
out of the mainstream but still relying
on the information coming from our
automation line for total proteins
immunoglobulins so forth
you have to acknowledge
the brilliant colleagues of mine at
Xavier Diagnostics John O'Leary Hannah
Dolan Steve McQueen my technical
specialist in special hematology here
Margie rizback
our regional electrophoresis team our
operators those who are performing these
tests day in and day out
my colleagues in pathology Dr Khan Dr
Kinney Dr valentire Dr Mirza and I would
be remiss if I didn't mention Dr r.o
Holmes who got this process started just
prior to his retirement so we owe him a
debt of gratitude as well and our Lis
team here at Loyola
so I'll be happy to address questions
for you and we will also be looking at
the polling questions as part of the
registration and how you responded but
even here in this slide I do see another
Peak so happy to address any questions
thank you for your participation today
thank you Dr Missouri for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen we'll answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for all right so let's get started our
first question here asks can you
describe the training for reviewers that
was provided by Savia application
specialists
I would characterize the training as
extensive and continuous so there are a
number of Library courses available on
the media lab format recorded by
specialist Dr Matthew Wagner takes us
through not only the immunofixation but
also the immunosubtraction principles
and
walks us through the interpretive
process as reviewers how to look at some
of these challenging findings so that's
one source that we also use in our
training of pathology residents and
fellows we also have a the ability of
the Sabia team to come on site and work
with the reviewers going through the
library of challenging cases in
PowerPoint format but also to have the
team work with the Sabia specialist
looking at our particular challenges
that we've encountered maybe during our
validation process maybe on an ongoing
basis in interpreting results and the
technical support team is available and
they do get back to you in within 24
hours if we have any challenges to our
interpretations that we would like to
escalate to a team that's a little bit
more familiar with these types of
findings
wonderful thank you I have another
question for you here this one asks what
method validation studies are required
for spe and I.T on the capillary threes
I'm glad someone brought that up because
I really didn't go into detail during my
presentation but we need to first of all
assess the reproducibility the Precision
when it comes to the the measurement or
the estimation of the area under the
curve of the albumin and the globulin
protein so we need to look at the
reproducibility at various
concentrations so Precision is part of
the validation as well as looking at the
reference interval so we have to look at
healthy ambulatory patients and how the
reference intervals for the for albumin
and the globulin fractions compare to
what we currently have established so is
there a need for two separate reference
intervals is there a way to look at
transferring the reference interval we
did have to adjust as I indicated
albumin and Alpha One and the gamma
components during our method validation
and finally extensive comparison testing
we looked at between 80 and 100 patients
with a monophonal protein present and
another 40 or so with no monoclonal
protein present and assessed for
agreement and where we saw discordance
did a thorough investigation as to what
the cause of the of the discordance was
great
we have some great questions coming in
from our audience and we have time for
just a few more here now I have this
next question that asks have you
retained the Ife gel-based testing and
if yes what is the main reason you
retain this testing
I'm glad this was asked because I do
want to emphasize this is not a
technology the gel-based testing is not
a technology we are looking to phase out
we're looking and we have decided to
retain this to assist us in the
interpretation of results that are
called into question maybe not so clear
especially in the proteins with very low
concentrations we're not so sure of the
degree of subtraction because there's
really not obvious Peaks there to begin
with so we like to look at this using
the gel based methods as well and I
think I indicated we're at about 15 to
20 percent right now of our immunotyping
where we start followed up with with the
immunofixation gels and we'd like to get
that down to 10 percent but this is
going to vary by sight based on your
population mix and how many patients are
being screened for
monoclonal proteins
great
another question here asks have you seen
an increase or decrease in detection of
monoclonal proteins since your
transition to the capillary three
and this was a concern of ours as well
what's going to happen when we implement
this testing so we've kept an eye on
this and we have noticed that we are
seeing an increase so due to the
increased sensitivity of the
immunotyping immunosubtraction and the
capillary principles we are seeing an
increase in positivity this is leading
to more diagnoses of monoclonal
gammopathy of undetermined significance
this mgus category which is uh causing a
more watchful weight type of of episode
for a number of patients but these were
patients that were previously
missed unfortunately because of the lack
of ability to detect the more subtle
increased staining of the of the gel
electrophoresis
thank you Dr Missouri as I mentioned for
the sake of time we'll
um ask one more question here and wrap
up so this final question asks for cases
where paraprotein is very low in
concentration or light chains disease do
you choose immunofixation rather than
immunosubtraction
we start with immunosubtraction in all
cases and we are challenged with the the
low concentration of the of the protein
low total concentration of the protein
we could apply what's called a hypogamma
dilution for these samples in other
words take a more concentrated look at
the proteins to see what our initially
visualized and then what become
immunosubtracted and we could always
turn to our gel electrophoresis to do
again a lesser dilution in that case to
see if we can better visualize what
appears to be the more subtle subtracted
peaks in that region so unless someone
asked that question as well since I
didn't talk about the hypogama dilution
mode during my presentation so thanks
for that question
first
well that will conclude our session for
today so I want to thank you again Dr
majorie for your time today and your
important research we would also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor Sabia
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
now before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
lab Roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event so until next time take care
everyone goodbye